you know there is some uh symmetry to
the show today we started with a network
tv morning show celebrating the grooming
and indoctrination of a young boy
we end with something tragically similar
in this case the today's show website
today.com features an article with this
headline
i wanted my son to reject masculine
stereotypes then he fell in love with
tractors
all my life i've prided myself on
blurring gender lines but when my young
son started to gravitate toward the very
things i'd shunned i wasn't sure what to
do
now the column is written by a guy named
j
uh dieter whose twitter bio tells us
he's a stay-at-home co-sleeping dad and
a recovering schmuck
that's how he describes himself
and it appears that his recovery is
not going well sadly
jay doing absolutely no favors to
stay-at-home dads who are worried about
negative stereotypes tells us that he
has he's done his best to indoctrinate
his young boy into being as effeminate
as he is but so far it has not gone
according to plan he writes quote
after turning two years old my son
avishai
that's the son's name started demanding
that he only wear tractor shirts and my
mind spiraled into darkness
i catastrophized worst case scenarios
imagining a world where he fell for
everything stereotypically manly i
envisioned him on a football field
barreling through mega muscled opponents
i imagined him waxing a sports car in a
warm summer day
yeah what a nightmare that would be
dear god imagine if your son becomes
athletic strong talented and financially
successful
who would want such a thing
who who would wish for such a curse upon
their son well certainly not house
husband jay who continues i've always
judged other guys who seemed boxed in by
masculinity but three and a half years
ago when i became a stay-at-home dad my
bias skyrocketed we co-slept and he
snoozed with his head resting on my
chest listening to the rhythm of my
heartbeat i began attending mommy and me
play groups and bristled when other
caregivers made jokes about me providing
daddy daycare
well at least we could take solace in
the assurance that the moms at the
playgroup are bullying jay
i kind of imagine him sulking in a
corner eating activia yogurt and crying
softly to himself
and that thought at least brings me some
joy
house husband jay continues i grimaced
at anyone driving a ford car the john
wayne of automobiles i hated men who
wore plaid
how dare you sir
i felt ill if somebody mentioned a
wrench or another tool when my
mom-in-law bought avishai a coverall
with footballs on it i shoved it into
the depths of his closet never to be
found
well this is some more good news for me
i guess i'm always looking to pad my
victim resume you know and kind of pad
my stats a little bit and now i know
that i've been discriminated against for
being a member of the plaid community a
person of plaid as we call ourselves pop
for short at least not be discriminated
against by one person and he just so
happens to be a man who actually wrote
the sentence
i felt ill if somebody mentioned a
wrench
and he didn't mean it as a joke
read just one more section of what is
certainly at least in the running for
the title of most pathetic diatribe in
human history he continues once my son
could walk i paraded him through the
park while he rolled his baby doll down
the sidewalk in his stroller
i felt accomplished because he mirrored
being a caretaker
but then came the tractors
it started with youtube one on days i
was especially drained i'd sit avishai
in front of the tv and click on little
baby bum
he fell in love with the tractor songs
and i was so worn i didn't care
when he asked to watch clips of
construction equipment i mindlessly
pressed play
but when he demanded the shirts i felt
like i failed him i pride myself on
blurring gender lines i wanted him to
also
okay i take it back this is not in the
running for the most pathetic diatribe
in human history
it has certainly won the title all other
competitors are left in its dust
house husband jay talks about his
toddler discovering tractors the way
that that most parents might talk about
their teenage son developing a heroin
addiction or something
he's devastated by it
though as the piece drones on and on and
on and on
the house husband eventually does come
around to sort of accepting his son's
masculine tendencies he's at least
accepted that he can't completely
deprogram his boy and turn him into a
into a girl yet
though i suspect he's not going to stop
trying
for now though and for the foreseeable
future his toddler son is manlier than
he is and he felt the need to write an
article and post it on today.com and let
us all know about that
now it's hard not to laugh at house
husband jay
um he certainly deserves all of the
mockery and bullying coming his way if
only he'd gotten a whole lot more of it
in his youth maybe it wouldn't have come
to this
but the laughter soon dies away when you
remember that there's an actual real
child caught in the middle of this
neutered man's self-hating neurosis
and it demonstrates again
one startling fact
that on the left
there's only one rule for children
okay they can be anything they want to
be
but they must become something other
than what they actually are
they must be raised to reject themselves
their true nature their authentic
identities
so it's not that and this is important
it's not that on the left it's not that
they hate masculinity per se
even jay himself who faints and vomits
at the sight of a socket wrench doesn't
despise the idea of masculinity he just
despises it when it's exhibited by men
he quite admires masculinity in women
which is why he's traded place with his
places with his wife and ceded the man's
role to her
leftists certainly don't have a problem
with brawny masculinity or pink and
frilly femininity
they just have a problem with those
things in their traditional settings
boys can be as frilly and feminine as
they like girls can be as masculine as
they like
the only time a girl should be
traditionally feminine is if
uh it's actually a boy identifying as a
girl just as the only time a boy should
be masculine is if the boy is actually a
girl identifying as a boy
the left has not waged war on
masculinity and femininity directly
it has instead ripped these things out
of their proper context and had them
sort of switch places with each other
now inevitably
both will perish in that operation just
as any tree dies when severed from its
roots
as maleness is the life-giving root of
masculinity and femaleness is the root
of femininity
but it's important to note just just how
they've gone about doing this
it's also essential to realize that
in a very strange and backwards sort of
way
leftists actually worship femininity and
masculinity
perhaps fetishize is a better word
that's what all the drag queen stuff is
about
they just don't like either femininity
or masculinity when they are found in
females and men respectively
they want to switch those two things
so the theme as always
is that people must reject who they are
be anyone you want to be
other than yourself
that's the core message
it's the religion that this man's son
will be tragically indoctrinated into
and that is ultimately why housewife
jenny is today canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated